in this video we're going to go through
how you can migrate a workload in this
case the payment service for an online
store from a virtual machine to a gke
autopilot cluster
before i dive into the core of the demo
let me say this demo assumes you are
already familiar with both migrate for
gke and gke autopilot if you're not you
might want to pause the video and go get
a quick overview of both of these
offerings and then come back and rejoin
me
with that being said let's go ahead and
take a look at where we're at this is
our initial architecture you can see the
payment service is there on the left in
blue and it's running in a vm when we're
done that will be migrated to a
container like all the other services in
the online boutique so let's go ahead
and take a look at that online boutique
and see it actually in action so i'm
going to go here and i'm going to click
on this barista set i'm going to add to
cart and i'm just going down and place
my order and you can see everything
works as expected lastly before we jump
into the migration i want to show you
the infrastructure real quick i have two
gke clusters one running migrate for gke
the other running the sample application
you can see that's an autopilot cluster
now if i click on workloads you can see
all of the services running there for
the online boutique to perform the
actual migration i'll start by running
an analysis using migrate for gke's
migration fit tool to see if our
workload is a good candidate for
migration
next i'll create a migration plan and i
edit it to specify that we want to
enable the resulting container to run on
gke autopilot from there i'll execute
the actual migration this will result in
a set of artifacts including a docker
file a container image and a pair of
yaml files
one to deploy the kubernetes services
and deployment and another to manage the
configuration of those primitives
i'll then deploy the newly migrated
workload using the kubernetes yaml
finally i'll edit the configuration for
the currently running services to point
them to the newly deployed kubernetes
service replacing the virtual machine's
dns name with the kubernetes service
name
the first step in any migration process
should be to ensure that the targeted
workload is a good candidate for
migration with the 1.8 release of
migrate for gke we've introduced via
public preview a new migration fit
assessment tool this tool can operate
against vms running on vmware vsphere by
directly interacting with the vsphere
apis or it can be run directly against a
single vm in the case of our demo today
i'm operating directly on the vm i want
to migrate which happens to be running
on google compute engine but like i said
it could just as easily be running on
vmware additionally migrate for gke also
supports migrating workloads from aws
and azure
let's go ahead and take a look at the
fit assessment tool in action i'll run
the fit assessment tool which will
gather information about the processes
and services running on my vm then i'll
import the resulting data which is
stored in a tar file into the fit
assessment database
i can use the ls command to get a list
of vms that i've gathered data from
previously
next i'll have the fit tool analyze the
collected information
once it's finished its assessment i will
have it produce a report on its findings
the report can be in html or json i'm
going to specify json so i can upload it
to the google cloud console later also
while i'm only analyzing a single vm in
this demo you can batch process this
analysis
now that i have the report i'm going to
upload it to the google cloud console
and you can see the result here my
application is a good fit for migration
if i want to see exactly what was found
on the vm i can drill down and take a
look here at some of the details
before i can actually migrate a vm i
need to stop it so let me move into the
shell here and issue the stop instances
command i'll speed up the video a little
bit and when that's finished we can move
on
so i've already created a processing
cluster and defined a source so let's
define our migration
we'll click create migration i'm going
to call it payment service we're going
to select the source i created earlier
it's linux and the vm name is payment
service vm we're going to use the image
intent we'll click create migration and
wait for that to finish
all right now we can move on so let's go
in and edit the actual migration plan
now i need to make a change in here to
ensure that the resulting containers can
run on autopilot so i'll come in and i'm
going to add an annotation up here near
the top so i'll hit enter and i'll paste
the annotation in then i'm going to
scroll down and i want to change the
service and the image name from payment
service vm to just payment service
so we'll change it here and we'll change
it here
we'll click generate artifacts that'll
take a few minutes so i'm going to speed
up this video
and rejoin you when it's finished
the migration is finished and i've
downloaded the resulting artifacts into
cloud shell so let's take a look at the
config.yaml file
the config.yaml file is used to control
a bunch of different aspects of the
container that's going to run including
what processes are running in the
container some things about the file
system and how it's laid out now i'm not
going to spend a lot of time here i just
wanted you to be aware of this file
because you may have to edit it in the
future
so let's go ahead and apply the
deployment spec.yaml that was generated
this is going to create two kubernetes
primitives the service and the
deployment so let's go ahead and take a
look at the pods and see if our new
service is up and running yet
it looks like it's actually still
pending so i'm gonna pause the video and
i'll rejoin you once it started
okay it's been a few minutes let's clear
the screen and take another look and it
looks like our
pod is up and running so let's go ahead
now we'll clear the screen again
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to go ahead and check out the
online boutique let's go ahead and get
the services so we can get that external
ip address and we'll copy that up
and we'll paste it in here and let's try
to buy something so the camera add to
cart
complete the purchase
you see an error now that's because
while i have the new service running my
vm is stopped and the application is
still trying to access it so what i need
to do is i need to add edit the
deployment spec for the actual
application and right here
you can see where we set that payment
service address so let me change that
from the dns name of the vm to the
service name of the kubernetes service
i'll save that out
we'll go back into the command line and
i'll apply that deployment spec so that
we can update the services to look not
at the vm but at that new container we
just deployed so we'll apply that out
you can see all the configuration
changes coming along here
and now i'm going to go ahead once again
make sure that the pods have started up
looks like the pod has started up
successfully so let's go ahead and move
back to the online boutique and let's
try to buy that camera again so we'll
click add to cart we'll click place
order and everything works as expected
we have migrated the payment service
from the virtual machine to a container
running on gke autopilot